à
envie de commencer mon
simplement remercier mes prédécesseurs
pour l'heure
l'intervention
leur excellente prestation je voudrais
juste les féliciter d'abord pour venir
devant vous présenter un sujet à nous
faire partager un peu de leur passion de
leur connaissance de leur savoir chose
qui n'est pas forcément facile faut le
savoir aussi et je voulais simplement à
les remercier en tout cas pour ce bon
moment en tout cas moi j'ai fait
beaucoup beaucoup de plaisir à les
écouter
j'ai appris beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et je tenais
à les remercier
vous vous dites il est gentil ce
bonhomme qu'est ce qu'il fout là il
vient il lance des fleurs à tout le
monde et de quoi il vient nous parler
alors ces quelques mots d'introduction
peuvent vous paraître anodin ces
quelques remerciements ces quelques
fleurs lancées un peu en vrac comme ça
ça peut vous paraître anodin mais c'est
juste pour vous mettre en avant un outil
que tout le monde a que tout le monde
possède et c'est un outil qu'est capable
de transmettre des émotions
c'est un outil qui est capable de de
transmettre des sensations très fortes
ça a tout d'un outil qui est capable de
motiver les gens il est capable
d'améliorer votre leadership et cet
outil tout le monde là tout le monde le
possède tout le monde peut l'appliquer
seulement cet outil est souvent mal
utilisés mal compris voire oubliés et
cet outil c'est simplement la
reconnaissance la reconnaissance envers
les gens
la reconnaissance qu'on peut avoir
envers un individu sur le travail qu'il
a fait reconnaître son travail
simplement c'est utile à la
reconnaissance tout le monde là est mon
propos aujourd'hui c'est de vous mettre
en avant vous faire prendre conscience
que tout le monde à cet outil tout le
monde peut l'appliquer
ça fait un peu plus de dix ans que je
suis dans le monde professionnel et j'ai
voulu traiter ce sujet après une
certaine frustration acquise de voir cet
outil a dans les mains des gens et ils
n'en font pas grand chose en fait
et c'est très frustrant de voir ce
potentiel ce gisement de motivation
qu'on peut donner aux gens très
facilement un simple merci un simple
remerciement et on n'en fait rien du
tout et c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
traiter ce sujet là
du coup ça m'amène un exemple assez
assez relativement simple gt gt en train
de développer une machine
j'étais en train de 2 excusez moi
j'étais en train de de préparer ce
rendez-vous de préparer cette
intervention justement et il ya quelques
semaines de cela dans l'audience il y
avait une personne une enseignante qui
qui écoutait mon sujet qui est qu'ils
écoutaient mais mon thème et qui est
venu me débriefer on a débriefé ensemble
en ai discuté et cette personne c'est
une ancienne amante elle m'a dit c'est
vrai c'est vrai que j'adore quand un
élève vient vers moi et me dit à la fin
du cours
merci merci parce que j'ai tout compris
simplement ça c'est magnifique
et c'est vrai que la personne cet ancien
nantes était transformée rien qu'en dix
ans et quelques mots rien qu'en écoutant
son élève dire merci pour cet
enseignement et je pense que vous avez
tout cet exemple là vous avez tout ce
professeur vous allez tous chez vous
raconter cette histoire d'un professeur
qui vous a marqué un professeur qui vous
a transporté dans son cours je pense que
je suis sûr et certain que vous avez cet
exemple là cet exemple qui quand vous
êtes rentré dans sa salle le ce prof est
dit ouah mais qu'est ce que je fous là
moi la chimie j'ai jamais rien panier ça
va être long cette année ça va vraiment
être très très longues qu'est ce que je
fous là et au final ce professeur à
force de persévérance
à force d'abnégation à force de deux
passions il va réussir à vous emmener
dans son cours il va vous réussi à vous
faire à vous transporter à vous
transmettre des émotions à vous faire
aimer peut-être la chimie il va vous
faire comprendre ce qu'est une molécule
ce qu'est la matière c'est qu'à une
réaction chimique il faut faire
comprendre plein de choses il ya
peut-être même vous faire découvrir une
vocation
et ce travail là tout le monde tout le
monde là cette histoire là en tête par
contre combien d'entre vous êtes allé
voir ce professeur à la fin de l'année
le regarder droit dans les yeux et lui
dire et lui serrer la main et lui dire
chapeau
chapeau monsieur parce que moi quand je
suis rentré dans votre cour je pas n'y a
rien du tout à ce qu'était la chimie par
contre aujourd'hui j'ai pris énormément
de plaisir à vous écouter à apprendre
vous m'avez transmis du savoir et j'ai
passé vraiment une année exceptionnelle
et maintenant la chimie je peux dire que
j'aime la chimie alors la chimie est un
exemple il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'autres
exemples
mais cet exemple c'est juste pour
montrer qu'avec des mots simples avec
des mots simples
vous pouvez aller voir ce professeur et
lui dire merci
maintenant imaginez ce professeur peut
être que très pudiquement ce professeur
va vous regarder va vous dire merci va
vous sourire mais imaginez maintenant
après qu'est-ce qui se passe ce
professeur cette même personne elle va
sortir de sa salle elle va commencer à
avoir des émotions parce qu'elle va
repenser au fait que son élève est venu
le voir pour lui dire merci
elle va avoir des sensations elle va
avoir des émotions dans son ventre et ça
ça ça n'a pas de prix
ça c'est exceptionnel cette personne
elle va avoir des ces petits papillons
dans le ventre quand elle va rentrer
chez lui elle va avoir le ce sentiment
de travail bien fait cette satisfaction
du travail bien fait et et puisqu'il a
pris beaucoup de plaisir qu'est ce qui
va se passer derrière le professeur il a
eu un élève et ben va peut-être en
vouloir avoir un deuxième un troisième
5/10 une classe entière qui le remercie
et qui ce qu'il va faire il va vouloir
donner plus va vouloir travailler plus
il va vouloir aller beaucoup plus loin
dans sa performance il va tout
simplement essayer d'être meilleur et
s'il essaie ici il essaye d'être
meilleur qui sait qu'il a en face de lui
c'est vous c'est vous qui allez récolter
derrière les fruits de sa de son
amélioration les fruits de son élévation
de performance si les plus performants
derrière vous allez récolter son
enseignement
il va vous transmettre son savoir et si
les plus performants vous allez devenir
plus performants et comme quoi avec un
simple mercier un simple remerciement
vous pouvez élever la compétence des
gens et c'est vous qui allez en profiter
c'est relativement simple la
reconnaissance c'est quelque chose de
vital
c'est quelque chose d'universel c'est
tout le monde en a besoin
c'est comme ça l'être humain est fait
ainsi on a besoin de reconnaissance et
il ya une donnée qui est très important
c'est très personnel c'est important de
personnaliser la reconnaissance la
reconnaissance ne s'applique pas à l'un
comme à l'autre
c'est quelque chose qui est très
différents en chaque individu je me
souviens d'une situation un peu d'une
anecdote où j'ai travaillé pendant deux
ans sur une machine sur un projet très
compliqué c'était une machine de
prototypage une machine l'innovation
donc on avait un une machine à amener au
bout et miracle on arrive au bout de ces
deux ans de travail a développé une
machine qui va au delà des espérances de
notre de nos grands chefs et parmi mon
équipe
il y avait une personne une automaticien
qui a abattu un travail colossal
vraiment monstrueux une au match mais
une automaticien haine qui par sa force
de proposition son abnégation sa
persévérance sa résilience à la pression
elle a fait un travail colossal et on
avait parfaitement conscience et à la
clôture du projet dont on peut imaginer
dans une salle on veut clore le projet
on veut montrer les résultats
les supers résultats qu'on a eus et
derrière on présente ça devant les
grands dirigeants et on imagine une
salle avec des grands dirigeants et au
moment de remercier mon équipe une fin
un laïus spéciale pour cet automaticien
parce qu'elle avait abattu un travail
considérable genre a envie de
reconnaître son travail et à la fin de
la réunion la personne vient voir une
courroie de droit dessus et me disent
vraiment très sèchement guy emile sa
dernière fois que tu me fais ça c'est la
dernière fois que ma fiche devant les
dirigeants
je me suis jamais senti aussi senti
aussi gêné aussi mal aussi
vraiment vraiment pas ma place et là je
me suis senti vraiment pris mon bet
deuxièmement me suis senti très mal pour
elle très mal pour moi je pars d'un bon
principe de reconnaissance derrière j'en
reçois l'effet inverse
tout ça pour dire que la reconnaissance
c'est une
c'est une matière un peu explosive à
manipuler il faut respecter quelques
règles
et une des règles les plus importantes
c'est d'abord de se connaître soi et de
connaître les gens qui vous entourent et
je vous encourage fortement à apprendre
à connaître les gens qui sont autour de
nous est-ce que c'est quelqu'un de
timide parce que c'est quelqu'un
d'introverti est ce quelqu'un est ce que
c'est quelqu'un qui aime bien la lumière
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui plutôt
préfère un remerciement face à face
c'est très important
plus vous connaissez les gens plus vous
pouvez être efficace dans votre
connaissance et dans la façon de
l'appliquer
le but du jeu c'est juste de placer le
bon curseur au bon moment et puisque et
puisque c'est important de connaître les
gens c'est ça peut éviter les erreurs
que j'ai pu commettre cet exemple c'est
juste une erreur que j'ai pu commettre
justement dans l'application
on partage un point commun mine de rien
c'est qu'on fait partie de la même
génération
vous savez cette génération qu'on
appelle la génération y est on a un
énorme sentiment
on a un énorme besoin de reconnaissance
ce besoin
on l'a il est dans notre génération les
générations antérieures la
reconnaissance pouvait être plus passive
les gens étaient plus passif plus
patient pour la recevoir
nous on a un problème c'est qu'on veut
tout tout de suite et cette
reconnaissance
on veut on veut là on veut la recevoir
on veut cette renonçons à cette notion
d'immédiateté pour recevoir la cette
reconnaissance donc notre génération à
ce besoin de reconnaissance
et nous quand on travaille quand vous
allez travailler on cherche à donner du
sens à ce qu'on fait on ne fait plus les
choses parce qu'on nous a dit de le
faire
on veut comprendre pourquoi on fait on
veut donner du sens à ce qu'on fait et
pour donner du sens la reconnaissance
est un outil est un outil très très
important on a vu que la reconnaissance
sa partie ça appartient à ces très
personnel c'est quelque chose de
générationnel c'est aussi c'est quelque
chose de très culturelle et puisque
c'est très culture est ce là que le bât
blesse c'est qu'en france
j'ai toujours l'impression qu'on a on
sait on en saisit pas le potentiel qu'on
les gens à se remercier à se congratuler
à se féliciter
on saisit pas le potentiel de cette
action pour avoir voyagé ce que vous en
que je vous encourage vivement à faire
pour vous inspirer d autres cultures
les anglo saxons par exemple sont très
forts dans cette dans cette approche ils
ont compris que il pouvoir retirer
retirer beaucoup de bénéfices auprès des
gens dans cette approche de la
reconnaissance
et c'est très important c'est très
important de pouvoir de pouvoir savoir à
qui on applique cette reconnaissance le
problème en france c'est que on l'a
d'abord tout le temps de manière
négative par l'aspect du manque de
reconnaissance
et ce manque de reconnaissance on peut
le subir une dernière anecdote c'est il
ya vraiment pas très longtemps j'ai un
mes collègues il avait travaillé pendant
deux ou trois ans sur une innovation sur
un tout petit produit dans l'auto et
c'est une innovation il avait bu chez
pendant vraiment fort pendant deux ans
et il arrive à la dépose d'un d'un
brevet il est vraiment content de son
travail et il est sûr et certain qui
peut déposer un brevet et l'aja vraiment
ouais voilà il est vraiment content de
lui et c'est vrai qu'ils avaient ils
avaient ils avaient fortement raison le
brevet faut savoir c'est justin une
symbolique très forte c'est quelque
chose qu'on va déposer à chaque fois que
vous avez une innovation on pense que
c'est l'innovation du siècle on va dire
ah çà çà çà me méritent un brevet grâce
à ça je peux bloquer tous mes copains
pendant 20 ans et je vais être
tranquille ça c'est l'innovation c'est
une symbolique très forte faut imaginer
un document officiel qui est accessible
à toute la communauté technique toute la
communauté scientifique avec son nom
dessus
c'est très symbolique est très très
forte et mon collègue sediba impeccable
je fais ça pour mon entreprise
l'entreprise est propriétaire donc c'est
elle qui va toucher 6 à royalties ou pas
et je voulais savoir il veut voir son
manager notre manager en l'occurrence il
lui demander comment ça se passe en
termes de reconnaissance moi j'ai
travaillé pendant deux ans comment on
reconnaît comment on récompense notre
travail intellectuel que j'ai fourni
pendant deux ans et avec un aplomb
incroyable
notre manager lui dis ouah ça peut faire
un peu ton métier quand même de me
sortir des brevets et donc je vous
imagine la taille de l'uppercut se prend
mon collègue ans dans les dents quand on
lui dit ça vaut quoi tu me racontes ça
moi même me suis juré se scotcher j'ai
dû penser que notre manager ils devaient
ils devaient s'imaginer qu'on sortait qu
on en sortait des brevets comme ça tous
les matins sur notre tartine dans la
poche
hop on a un brevet en est génial en il
du pétrole mais maintenant s'avérait que
il connaissait pas vraiment notre
fonction et connaissait pas vraiment sur
quoi on travaillait et ça a pêché mon
comme mon collègue en l'occurrence venez
chercher de la reconnaissance il est
reparti en dise on voit si j'ai mis deux
ans qu'une quiche en fait tous les
autres qui met trois semaines à sortir
quelque chose peut-être que je suis
mauvais en tout cas je suis pas fait
pour l'innovation je sais pas vous
imaginer l'impact derrière donc vous
pouvez le subir vous pouvez le subir
cette ce manque de reconnaissance
faites attention utiliser les bonnes
règles et si vous utilisez bonne règle
croyez moi vous pouvez transmettre des
émotions très fortes et c'est important
de transmettre des émotions
le corps humain est relativement bien
foutu un corps humain il a cette mémoire
émotionnelle qui fait que quand on va
transmettre des émotions quand on va
recevoir des émotions ses petits
papillons souvenez-vous du professeur
ces petits papillons qu'ils avaient dans
le vent en sortant de sa salle
vous pouvez les transmettre et vous
pouvez en recevoir également
et puisqu'il ya cette intelligence
émotionnelle cette mémoire émotionnelle
vous avez souvenirs et peut-être que si
vous allez rencontrer cette personne
demain après demain dans six mois dans
cinq ans dans dix ans que sais-je
et vous avez eu demandez vous allez
l'insolite solliciter son aide
elle va peut-être se souvenir que vous
lui avez transmises et transmis des
émotions va peut-être se souvenir de
cette petite touche de reconnaissance
que vous avez eue avec lui et ça sera
peut-être à son tour de recopier le même
schéma et de vous transmettre ses
émotions et c'est à votre tour que vous
allez bénéficier et c'était travaux tour
de sortir quelque chose dans vos tripes
tout ça pour vous dire que la
reconnaissance c'est très puissant
par contre c'est comme l'arrosage ça
doit se pratiquer un petit peu tous les
jours donc je vous encourage à pratiquer
cette reconnaissance auprès les gens qui
vous entourent de la pratiquer dès
aujourd'hui dès maintenant dès à présent
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]